in the past I did a number of videos
talking about my own philosophical
development and a lot of these centered
around what I call phases where I was
like super into this kind of thing for a
while and then I didn't completely leave
it behind necessarily but I I moved on
to something else and I've also done
some that have to do with like
people who've become a lasting part of
my own philosophical conversation all
the stuff that's going on in my head the
interests that I've got so you know once
I got into Aleister McIntyre never
really left him behind same thing with
Aristotle the stoics Mary woolstone
craft right and what I'm going to talk
about now is a little bit different it's
kind of distinct from those but it also
incorporates those and it is philosophy
understood as a way of life a way of
living this is a particular
orientation to philosophy that has been
there really in the west from the start
and I would say in a lot of non-western
philosophy too it is really centrally
important
and for me as the kind of person that I
am and coming from the background that I
have and the interest that I I have it's
always been part of how I
understood and did and studied
philosophy and talked about it and
showed interest in it
now it's
quite striking that in recent years I
have become aware and when I say recent
years like the last decade of this guy
Pierre Ado and
um you know his famous sort of
Catchphrase philosophy as a way of life
for example in this very important book
which I have students read by the way
um and you know there's other texts that
are quite good recently uh the selected
writings of pirado following up with
this translated by Matthew sharp and
Federico Testa here's another great new
book that came out by Matthew sharp and
Michael Ura philosophy is a way of life
history Dimensions directions
and you know when you encounter Ado
um for the most part I've run into him
in terms of uh people who were
interested in Hellenistic philosophy and
saying ah this is really important it's
not like
um
it's not like contemporary analytic or
Continental philosophy it was supposed
to have a direct application to the way
that you live the way that you not only
make decisions you know ethical matters
but also aesthetic matters and to how
you organize your household and how you
carry out your studies how you transform
yourself as a human being so I have been
without realizing that it was called
philosophy of way of life I've been
doing this my entire career as a student
and then teacher of philosophy and this
goes all the way back you know
officially to 1990 so we're talking 33
years at this point when I first entered
College I was interested in philosophy
already in in kind of a hazard you know
whatever I could encounter sort of way
in high school and then while I was in
the arm Army and and you know I would
read a lot but I wasn't reading in any
sort of organized way and I would just
pick up you know whatever I thought was
interesting I did have uh two philosophy
classes that could read an article about
I'll link to it below when I was in high
school one was terrible and that was the
official philosophy class one was really
quite helpful and that was actually a
sacraments class that the instructor
turned into a philosophy class
so
you know I never really had the idea of
studying philosophy so I could become a
college professor even when I was in
college what I really wanted to do was
to write and I I considered at one point
actually dropping philosophy as a major
and picking up English you know slash
writing as a substitute for it but
fortunately the writing teacher I talked
to so that's a terrible idea stick with
philosophy that way you'll have
something to write about you know and I
was you know always motivated by the
idea of taking philosophy and doing
something with it I I wanted I'm not
going to say I was purely pragmatic but
I definitely
wanted whenever we read a text or
um you know talked about this stuff to
understand well what what do we do with
this how how would the world if I look
at it Through The Eyes of a manual not
how does the world look different for me
and how does that affect what I choose
what I commit to what I refuse what I
get away from
what what do I how do I relate to other
people how do I relate to Beauty in in
nature or in movies or music or any of
these sorts of things
so for me philosophy was always
something to be studied and also just as
importantly to live out and experiment
with
now pirado is not saying that some
people interpret him you know this was
something that they did and ancient
philosophy and medieval philosophy and
then people lost sight of it and we
became a bunch of University professors
I mean he says that the existentialists
are doing philosophy as a way of life in
this this very book philosophy as a way
of life I think that this book is
particularly good by Matthew sharp and
Michael Ura because it talks about you
know Socrates and epicureans and the
stoics goes through the medievals and
early moderns talks about you know
Descartes and Francis Bacon and the
French Enlightenment which was lived it
was something that you did and then you
know brings up um schopenhauer and
Nietzsche uh Michelle Foucault
um you know and what the prospects are
for the present I would say that
philosophy as understood as a way of
life is much much broader than even what
they're talking about I'll just give you
one prime example this is the guy I
wrote my dissertation on this is his
most important early work locks you know
1893 Maurice Blondell essay doing
critique
which means an an essay or you know a
sort of like attempt at a critique of
life and a science of practice so you've
got action Science Life
practice all of these things connected
together
that's what this guy was doing and he's
not unique in that respect you know uh
Henry bergson is paying attention to
that Gabriel Marcel one of the first
people to talk about existentialism in
French right uh we could multiply these
instances
studied with to some degree um we could
go on and on and on and on
philosophy understood as a way of living
has not been absent even within the
universities you just gotta know where
to look you got to know which professors
to check out which authors to read who
the sympathetic ears are who are the
people interested in trying things out
and seeing what sort of difference a
philosophy makes in our life offers us
and so the existentialists are great for
that of course the American pragmatists
and American philosophy in general think
about Thoreau and Emerson and Eve going
even back further some of the figures
before them and the intersections
between philosophy and literature or
drama or history the humanities in
general they can be an abstract academic
thing that we do to write monographs but
there can also be something that is
incredibly vital
something that touches Us in the core of
our being
and that's what philosophers a way of
life really aims at
there's a few other things I need to say
about this one is that there's different
names for this sort of thing you know
Maurice Blondell didn't use the term
philosophy as a way of life like I know
did later this is philosophy as a way of
life he's talking about the philosophy
of action the method of imminence the
method of implication you know a
metaphysics of Charity and all sorts of
things like that that's philosophy is a
way of life somebody else who I was very
influenced by for a while Jean-Paul sart
his form of existentialism philosophy is
a way of life right there you know and
we could go on and on and on
um we mentioned Michelle Foucault
Michelle Foucault doesn't talk about
spiritual exercises or philosophy is a
way of life instead he talks about
Technologies of the self it's the same
thing
Aleister McIntyre coming a little bit
later you know we'll we'll talk about uh
from after virtue onward tradition
constituted moral inquiry that's still
philosophy is a way of life and the
practices that are involved in that
incredibly important and philosophy is a
way of life can very often involve
critique of the prevailing culture that
you're within and its products and
thinking about where you're situated
within it that's something from ancient
philosophy all the way to the presence
you know McIntyre before he starts
writing things like after virtue and
who's Justice which rationality has a
lot of culture critique like against the
self-images of the age all of that is
philosophy and understood as a way of
life
as a matter of fact I'll bring up
another thinker somebody I highly
recommend Antonin certiage a great 20th
century Thomas he has a book called The
intellectual life which is essentially
philosophy as a way of life he's a
contemporary of 18 Angel song and
Maurice Blondell and all these people
and took part in the Christian
philosophy debates with them where Emile
Breyer the great historian of philosophy
kind of a young punk at the time
sad about Maurice Blondell that his work
was basically not that philosophical not
like Plato and Aristotle be precisely
because like the stoics and the
epicureans it was concerned more with
life than with abstract thought so this
this idea has been around a long long
time and if you you know read
attentively authors like Renee Descartes
or Thomas Hobbes you see them incredibly
concerned with how you actually apply
philosophy and what its effects are and
how it can transform not just your mind
but your heart and your person and we
see later thinkers you know for example
in phenomenology like Mark Shaler
influenced by Augustine you know who are
doing this sort of thing as well so
there's lots and lots of possibilities
for reading philosophy in this way so
that's the first thing I wanted to to
sort of clarify another thing I want to
clarify is
you know philosophy is a way of life is
interconnected with history of
philosophy and very often in philosophy
in the present at least in the United
States and other places there is this
big contrast between two different ways
of doing philosophy there's analytic
philosophy then there's Continental
philosophy and anybody who's read widely
enough knows that this supposed analytic
Continental Divide is just a little tiny
bit of the vast world of philosophy
that's out there
so you know there's not only a tier team
quid a third possibility there's a you
know fourth and a fifth and a sixth and
a seventh we could go on and on and on
and where do you find a lot of these
well in the history of philosophy so you
know you can take a figure
um who's in you know the Continental
side like Nietzsche and you can get away
from the weird wacky trendy stuff and so
I just want to read nature and see what
the hell this guy actually has to say
and whether it's all BS or whether it's
applicable to my own life and my
relations with other people and my
connection to the culture and now you're
doing philosophy as a way of life you
might also be doing history of
philosophy thinking okay how did
Nietzsche's thoughts develop what are
they responding to that's real important
but from the perspective of philosophy
as a way of life you are really uh
interested in how does this change the
way that I live what can I do with this
what kind of life does this turn into
for me and that's really important and I
would say that is a vital part of
philosophy that if your professors or
your guides or whoever else tells you to
ignore that's not for you they're full
of crap this is what makes philosophy
something so vital and awesome for us
the fact that we can actually take so
many great thinkers that we have in this
long history of philosophy and get
ourselves into a kind of communication
with them and say this is this is worth
thinking about how do I do something
with this in a certain sense we're all
experimenting we're all pragmatists in a
certain sense we're all trying to see
we're you know we're empiricists we're
seeing what can we actually do with this
stuff
and it could be somebody who's very
rationalist like Renee Descartes if you
read Descartes writes and you take to
heart some of the things that he's
saying
he can change your life
he can change your mindset
and you might not necessarily buy into
everything but you can certainly take
what's useful for you
and get a lot of mileage out of it
so this is something well worth thinking
about I do want to mention a little bit
about my own path with this and you know
as I said at the start I've always
looked at philosophy in this way even
before I knew this was a thing and I
will say that not everybody I've run
across has been receptive to this there
sometimes you get accused of
popularizing or dumbing down philosophy
because you're looking at it in this
this sort of way or pandering to the
masses what you're doing isn't real
philosophy but you know you can just
kind of ignore that because no matter
what position you take no matter who
you're studying there's going to be some
jerk who probably is envious of you or
doesn't understand you and it's going to
give you a hard time right so don't
worry so much about that I would say as
as advice
I would like to say something about the
path that I took that wound up with me
doing philosophy as a way of life or
understood as a way of living
and as I remarked I've been doing this
really since the beginning when I
formally started studying philosophy as
an undergraduate along with mathematics
in 1990 so 33 years ago
and you know coming from the background
that I did where you know there's not a
lot of academics in my family there are
some people in professional life
we always wanted to know what you can do
with ideas and you know I kind of
resisted that you know there was this
reductionism of what's your actual
product why do people why do you think
people will pay you to study and do
philosophy and I you know I'm not
trying to reduce it to just that but I
always did want to know well what would
you do with this how do you live your
life as a person interested in
philosophy how do you how do you apply
this kind of stuff within the scope of
your relationships you you know the
workplace uh your connection to the rest
of the world your understanding of
yourself and your development so you
know I mentioned that I had some
philosophy in high school and then you
know I studied a little bit while I was
in the Army and then I became a
philosophy major and the place where I
went to school
you know the professors were near the
end of their career not particularly
interested in learning about what the
philosophical landscape was like in the
moving into the 90s
they had some kind of weird ideas about
you know analytic philosophy is just uh
ordinary language philosophy and logical
positivism that stuff's gonna die out
soon anyway and you know in Continental
philosophy it was Marxism and
existentialism where the big thing and
then you know they they thought that uh
classical American pragmatism and
process philosophy were big stuff too
and you know if you know anything about
the history of philosophy you know that
process philosophy was kind of Dead in
the Water by then and pragmatism was you
know becoming more and more of a
specialty right not a lot of people
engaging in that except at certain
places like where I went to graduate
school Southern Illinois University
and so while I was in undergraduate
there was a lot of you know my studying
things on my own you know for instance
really getting into sart and other
existentialists I was very into uh
philosophy and its intersection with
mathematics not just in logic but in you
know philosophy of mathematics and what
you could model and you know that was
about application as as well and I got
into philosophy of language in part
because I was interested in languages
and I wanted to know how they worked and
what the prospects for them were and so
you know then I I came out of undergrad
and I worked for a year worked on my
languages studied quite a lot and then
went to graduate school at Southern
Illinois University Carbondale and while
I was there
I got introduced to a whole wide world
you know it was a pluralistic department
so that meant there were analytic
philosophers Continental philosophers
classical American philosophers a few
people interested in the history of
philosophy you could go and study
rhetoric with the English people you
could go to the classics departments and
work on your languages as I did I
studied Greek with them and also learned
Latin on my own and all of that you know
at first I was very very interested in
language and anybody doing philosophy
language so a lot of Continental a lot
of uh analytic philosophy and then that
opened up the door for me to you know
study and read philosophers in their
original languages at least if they were
in you know French which I already had
German Latin or Greek and so I began
studying ancient philosophy and medieval
philosophy and you know of course
reading Descartes I read him in Greek
and in Latin and same thing with leibniz
and you know red Hegel in German and
Ninja and German and Heidegger in German
and so I I gathered an appreciation for
what it was that these these great
philosophers were putting in front of us
not just as like you know something for
us to engage
purely abstractly but something for us
to sort out our own lives in relation to
and that was you know that was kind of a
big thing at Southern Illinois
University that I really appreciate
now when I left oh by the way you know I
did my dissertation as I mentioned on
Blown Dell right so very much concerned
with ethical issues and with action
when I left my very first teaching
position was at Indiana State Prison
teaching for Ball State University and
these inmate students were very
interested not just in philosophy as
something to study and enjoy and have
some you know intellectual engagement
with but what would this do for them
what could it say about their own lives
their existence the day-to-day struggles
that they went through their attempts to
make sense of who they were and their
relationships and the world that they
were living in and how they would change
themselves for the better or if they
even needed to or wanted to
and so some of them responded to
different authors you know that's where
through their eyes and their voices I
got reinforced for myself how important
philosophy understood as a way of living
could actually be and so this is you
know quite important for me I I
developed a lot on my part and I hope
that they developed through my classes
as well and then you know I my next
teaching job after the prison job ended
was at Fayetteville State University
historically black University in North
Carolina and there I was teaching
critical thinking classes and there was
a lot of like well this is actually
going to be important for you to think
about how to be a good citizen how to be
a good consumer how to not get screwed
over by people but I also got to teach a
few philosophy classes so I taught an
intro class that was oriented towards
love and friendship and desire
I taught an African-American philosophy
class as part of a learning community
and that was really quite interesting
and and you know good development stuff
for me
um and then you know I did a lot of sort
of Hands-On here's how people learn
let's figure out how to make the classes
better for my my students then I went on
to Marist College where I was an adjunct
and I've adjuncted at several other
places and I will say just to bring this
to a close I don't want this to get
overly long
that in my classes and in my commitments
with you know
presentations and Consulting and clients
I'm always interested in well what do
you actually do with philosophy with
these philosophers with these ideas
these systems how can you
use this stuff how can you incorporate
this what kind of life will this lead to
or how will it change your life studying
it and I think I managed to communicate
that to a lot of my students and that's
part of what made my classes worthwhile
and interesting for them this is what
they tell me in like teaching
evaluations or they write me five years
later and they're like hey I actually
use this idea from your class I just
wanted to let you know and I think
that's really important I'm not saying
that's the only way to do philosophy I
think that it's perfectly fine for there
to be Specialists who are just you know
doing history of philosophy over here
uninterested in what what application it
would be have or be or anything like
that and I think it's fine for there to
be people doing you know analytic and
Continental philosophy in ways that may
feel like they're applied but but
actually aren't I mean not to knock it
there are quite a few people in those
fields who are doing some really great
work on you know key issues
but I think that we do need space for
this vital dimension of philosophy
philosophy understood as contributing to
our lives as a guidance for our lives as
offering us tools and insights and
exercises and perspectives and perhaps
even you know narratives on the part of
philosophers about their their own
experience and their own growth and we
need to have dialogue about this so you
can tell I'm you know pretty committed
to this this is something I've been
thinking about for quite a long time and
uh you know if if you're inclined in
that way that's part of why you study
philosophy or you might even be
considering studying philosophy
I'll end by just saying this
there is an incredibly Rich world out
there awaiting you for you to study that
I think you would do quite well to
engage with and you know if you want to
read people like
Pierre Adobe more power to you
but you can do philosophy as a way of
life without ever encountering him as
well so that's all that I have to say
about this it's already quite a lot and
hopefully this has been if not helpful
for you or you know enlightening for you
at least interesting and possibly
entertaining